welcome to the foundations of paid
search i'm brad gaddis the author of
advanced google adwords the bbc faculty
chair for markomotive in this video
we're going to explain what is ppc often
known as pay-per-click paid search or
even sem for search engine marketing
so ppc is really the act of buying
traffic on search engines such as bing
or google ask.com yahoo so forth and for
a lot of companies this is their primary
metric for new customer acquisition
you've ever done a search before on
google or bing you've seen ads or
sponsored results at the top of the
pages these are the ads we're talking
about the search ads these are often the
very first parts of the search engine
result page that a user sees when
conducting a search
now often advertisers want to know how
big a channel really is and how much
traffic can they get from any
advertising medium when we look at
search search encompasses a little more
than 6 billion search queries every
single day
the largest search engines are bing
yahoo and google and the goal then is to
take some of these search queries from
they're relevant to your business and
bring traffic to your website so you can
get customers
your ads can also be shown across the
display network now the display network
are other sites that show ads on them
that have partnered with google or bing
to display advertisements so this is
commonly new sites it may be things even
social sites such as facebook
and these sites then
are places that you can show your ads on
them that aren't searched but are more
akin to banner type ads you've seen
now these may be text ads there may be
images that might even be video ads and
you can choose to have them displayed
based upon words user interests um
contextual targeting methods and even
things such as remarketing which is
where someone does a particular behavior
on your website already and then you
show ads back across this network to
them so for instance you might be
looking at vacation getaway packages and
then you're thinking about it
considering it but then you leave the
site
let's say okay now you're over here
reading about a new computer something
totally different on a different website
but because you did specific actions on
their site they might show you ads then
on this third party site about getaway
packages and so when you look across the
display network there's a lot of
different very specific ways you can
reach users that are not quite searched
search is a very
relevant based industry but it comes
pretty close to search when you combine
all the options
and so by looking at both search and
display across page search you can be
incredibly specific of when you want a
user to see your ad
where they're based and then what
conditions are involved that make an add
display to any one user
now page search is an auction based
system so every time a search happens
then an auctions run to decide where
your ads will be displayed
now paid search is called paid search
because you do pay for the traffic
however you only pay for traffic that
comes to your website so it's free to
have your ad displayed you only pay when
you get traffic from a search engine to
your website